all right we are now
live for the may ama
uh this is the ask me anything session i
do these monthly
so i'm coming in a little bit early
because i see we've already got a lot of
questions
here and let me say hi to mark
mark smith he asks uh what do you think
is plato's worst dialogue and why is it
the laws
so it's one of those things that we call
a loaded question like uh have you quit
beating your
wife lately um you know it's it's kind
of funny
there i actually have a story about
about the laws um
i think it's it's actually pretty good
and i but you know i'm always looking at
plato
not to have these uh works as single
things by themselves but to like fill in
details about the platonic way of
looking at things
and so when i was in graduate school
i read vindlebond's history of
philosophy
and he called the laws plato's senile
work you know which i think was a very
common point of view
among german scholars at the time about
plato's
works and and there's no craziness that
some german scholar won't come up with
in terms of interpreting plato in the in
the 19th century
and i bought into that which was stupid
to do without reading the laws for
myself and i was like well why would i
read
them then and then when i read them
later on i thought oh this is actually
pretty good stuff
so that's uh you know kind of a
a lesson learned right um all right let
me jump up to the
to the top isaac says do you have any
favorite or preferred text on the
subject of free will
um i mean i don't have a favorite i i
usually don't have favorites about
much of anything these days i i will
have like
things that i i do like in general as a
matter of fact that would be a good
video to do like a
you know top 10 works on a particular
topic
i don't i don't talk much about free
will because i think that
the waters have been so muddied by
people using that term
in all sorts of ways i'm i'm less
interested in
you know that as like a free will or not
free will and more like
okay it's clear that we do have some
some degree of freedom how do we
conceptualize that
how do we make sense of that is there
any way to augment that freedom
are there things that restrict our
freedom and i would say if you if you
look at it in that way
we've already got discussions happening
in aristotle
important discussions in um not just
nico mccann ethics book three but also
in politics and other places as well
where he's considering what's voluntary
and involuntary and how we should you
know
look at the actions that people do and
then we've got the stoics and this is
clearly a central issue for the stoics
and i think that's that's quite
interesting
the epicureans definitely felt this to
be an issue
because we know this from cicero's on
fate and they kind of screwed it up
you know with their appeal to the the
swerve um
and then it just goes on from there
right we've got some really great
discussions
in early christian literature by
not just augustine who everybody goes to
but also boethius
after augustine john cassian roughly a
contemporary
um you know some some others as well and
you know one of my big favorite authors
uh in general uh somebody i keep going
back to over and over again i i know i
just said i don't have a favorite but if
i if i could only
pick one person who i've done the most
work on anselm of canterbury very
important thinker
thomas has some interesting things to
say descartes has some interesting
things to say
hobbs has interesting things to say
they're clearly wrong
and we can go on and on from there so
there isn't like a
single author to go to i i could
recommend a book to you though by uh
michael freida
called a free will which is which is
actually quite
quite good and worth taking a look at
there's a few points
where i disagree with it but it's worth
checking out
uh dammit albert says i was wondering
what thinkers do you think deal
best with the idea of evil and the
atrocities of the 20th century
so again not a great person to ask about
that because i don't see the
the atrocities of the 20th century as
unique
um i think that the you know evil has
been around for a very long time it may
have been
facilitated by you know mechanization
and things like that but i don't see it
as
as radically unique and i actually when
i saw that question coming up i went to
my bookshelf
this is a book by my mentor in graduate
school garth gillen
and it's you know it's sort of typical
for for his
his take on things he thinks that the
holocaust
and you know the holocaust can be sort
of crystallized into auschwitz
the way that people in holocaust studies
often do it
presents a unique challenge to
rationality
to goodness to whatever we want to think
about and i
my take was why is that you know it's a
horrible
set of events right but why is that
privilege why isn't rwanda
and the genocide there uh in many
respects just as bad
or why isn't you know when louis
ferdinand celine and
voyage says um
you know where world war one was
in french he calls it you know to this
this job of getting yourself
killed right the carnage that went on
there why is that not
not as bad um and you know dostoevsky
and notes from the underground talks
about
the horrors people are inflicting on
each other as well
in our civilized age and we can go back
you know further and further and further
i don't i don't see that as radically
unique so i in a way i don't i don't
have
the premise doesn't work for me so i
don't have a good answer
to that aaron asks
can i talk about the ethics and ai
specifically conscious
ai is the coexistence of humans and
conscious ai
rational i don't think at this point we
actually have any ai in a real
sense you know we we have when we use
the word
intelligence or we use the word like
learning and machine learning these are
very metaphorical
um we don't really have i mean we have
conscious ai
is in the sense of being conscious of
its inputs
and um you know maybe to some degree
it's processes
but we don't have self-conscious ai at
this point even if it can
even if ai's can use the word self that
doesn't mean that it's actually
self-conscious because it's just still
you know following it's it's programming
um now that said i do i think that we'll
never have
self-conscious ai you know i i wouldn't
hazard a guess on that and if we do then
you know we're gonna have to deal with
some serious issues that fortunately
have been brought up quite a lot
in speculative fiction you think about
isaac asimov
and the attention he devoted to that or
you know later on
iron banks or some other you know some
other key
thinkers and i think that can be drawn
upon
we definitely will i mean actually this
is a good question
the part about is the coexistence
itself rational so you know we human
beings
and again you see this a lot of
speculative fiction
we can sometimes get pretty worked up
about ai like you know let's let's smash
it all it's all terrible
right um it's gonna kill us all it's
gonna enslave us and turn us into
batteries like in the matrix
well um you know we don't want people
whose
knee-jerk reactions are that deciding
the policies that we're going to pursue
we also don't want people who are you
know
rational in a deficient sense and by by
this i mean the people who are you know
uh they don't necessarily have to be
stem lords
but but it sure helps for them to be you
know of that that persuasion that stem
rules the universe
and they're insufficiently rational and
they think that they're the most
rational people out there
because they haven't integrated the
affective and rational sides of
ourselves and they lack a lot of
self-consciousness
as a result we don't want them deciding
policy either
so you know it's probably going to be
one of those sort of things where
you know like with democracy democracy
is the worst of all political systems
except for all of the rest the people
that we have deciding policy if we were
to pick the best people
it would probably be those who are the
worst except for everybody else
right so all right
uh johann says i liked your video on
mcintyre can you
help me understand his critique of the
genealogical tradition especially in
three rival versions of moral inquiry
thank you for your work
i mean his his critique and and i
wouldn't use the word critique there i
would
i would i would because critique implies
something you know kind of conscient
or just making random criticisms i would
say his engagement with the genealogical
tradition because remember for mcintyre
it's very very important that
whatever tradition we're coming from if
we want it to be a healthy tradition
it's got to engage you can say
critically engage if you want
engage the other traditions and see what
they have to say about our own tradition
and whether those you know points that
it makes are are
worthwhile or not and we might even want
to you know like incorporate some of
them and we also have to understand like
where they're
coming from so there's a couple parts we
could talk about where
where is genealogical stuff coming from
well it's it's very clear and actually
this this ties in
with a different uh set of issues as
well that i'll come to
in a minute having to do with modernism
and post-modernism
it's very clear that if you look at like
nietzsche as a genealogical thinker or
you know another person
that we could look at is foucault you
know um
rousseau is also a genealogical thinker
too by the way before before nietzsche
they're using the resources developed
within
late modern culture against itself to
say
you're not the universal culture that
you pretend to be
and mcintyre thinks they're right in
that you know he thinks that's very
useful um where they go wrong is in
saying well it's all just a matter of
power
it's all just a matter of perspective or
you know is
shooting out some utopian projects
like you know nietzsche's uber match or
things like that
rather than working for something right
here and now that would be a
construction right so that's
um i would say that's that's the the
nutshell of it and i mentioned modernism
and post-modernism you know people who
complain about post-modernism usually do
so in ways that are distinctively
post-modern
um and the post-modern is not something
radically new
it's something that emerges from the
modern as the modern becomes
hypercritical
and is able to examine itself and
realize that it doesn't have the
doesn't have what it pretends to be you
know like the the way for human humanity
to go forward
so you know mcintyre in three rival
versions
is criticizing that uh
previous what he called the
enlightenment project in terms of
encyclopedia
um genealogy is what comes out of the
failure of that and then we have the
possibility of
you know um moving into something
something old and something new
you know
rainy mcgee says i cannot wait for this
episode i have a question regarding
rousseau and his stance on education and
art
i don't see a question there let me look
down
and see if there is a question i don't
see a question
i might not have a good response on
rousseau and art because i don't know
much about what rousseau has to think
about art
but um couldn't hurt to put it in there
josiah so when i read this i laughed a
little bit
in evangelical circles i've often heard
a distinction made between religion and
christianity for example religion is
about rules
christianity is about a personal
relationship and religion
is man trying to reach god christianity
is god reaching man
is this common in other forms of
christianity and what are your thoughts
on it
so i'm going to say something that may
piss people off here
you know how like uh there's that saying
there's no there's nothing so silly that
a philosopher hasn't said it
evangelicals are that squared there is
no
silly ungrounded thing that that could
be said that some evangelical has not
come up with
and then 30 other evangelicals were like
oh yeah man that sounds
awesome this is one of them it is it is
so
so prototypical you know um
and all you have to do is a little bit
of comparative um
literature you know look at looking at
religions
to see that this is complete [ __ ] um
these these sweeping generalizations
like that they sound
really great in sound bites or on key
chains or
at the pulpit but i mean they're
intellectual garbage
um i mean all you have to do is like
read
my ana buddhist literature and you see
that you know the buddhas
and bodhisattvas are also you know
beings of mercy reaching out towards
human beings
um and you know the way that a lot of
evangelicals today live
is is christianity the way that they
express it god reaching out to man or is
it really a control process
or purity codes or stuff like that yeah
you know i mean
the other thing you can say too is uh
you want 20 different opinions
ask 20 different evangelicals there is
no like doctrinal continuity there's
only this like constant churn of
of new slash old stuff getting
regurgitated
and when when people start looking into
like church church history and not just
like crappy
knockoff you know
textbooks on it but actually reading you
know church fathers like the ones i got
down below on the shelf
they quickly quit being that brand of
christianity
and they often gravitate back into some
sort of
much more liturgical church you know
that or or they leave and they they
become something else instead so
yeah i wouldn't put any credence in that
um
drew asks favorite reading spot reading
habits any rituals
so i mean this is one of my favorite
reading spots um sitting here in my
ames chair actually knock off aim's
chair i think real ames chairs are very
very expensive um you know in my my with
my books behind me
and cup of coffee i like reading in bed
as well
i also like reading in the bath um and
uh turns out that that's not just like a
churchill thing
but um somebody else who i found out
when i was you know like uh
doing that seminar with him that that
greatly enjoys doing that sort of stuff
is mcintyre it's kind of surprised to
discover that but also heartened
um you know i like going to coffee
houses when
when covet isn't an issue and sitting
there and reading
um i like frequenting used bookstores we
have a really nice one just
just a couple blocks from here libraries
you know i like reading um
when i'm traveling but i don't have any
rituals
um i am not a big ritual kind of person
when it comes to most things i don't
find them
particularly useful if i want to read i
just read you know
i don't need any particular way of doing
it but then again
i've been reading since
i've you know i my memories go back to
being about three years old that's when
i began reading
my mom took a lot of time with me as a
kid to teach me
how to read and then i just took off
from there we had encyclopedias my dad
taught me mathematics starting when i
was when i was four
you you know and he suckered me in
because he had one of the first
calculators
uh you know that that was hand-held and
i got to play with it
um so i don't i don't ever remember a
time when i wasn't
reading and actually i do remember
when i did learn to read picking off my
parents
as we were driving in the car one of my
memories is
we're driving in the car and i was
reading out loud all the street signs
and all of the you know like uh you know
stop signs and yield signs and stuff
like that and finally my dad turned to
me and he said it's great that you're
reading but you really have to shut up
about that
because i don't want to hear another
street side again so
yeah all right rima um
i've been reading the star of redemption
by frank rosenweig lately
and if i have any thoughts on it i don't
because i haven't read it since grad
school
so it's been a very long time and i
don't really remember much of
what i read from it uh peter says i'm
reading through thomas aquinas selected
writings and was wondering if you
suggest also reading ibn cena
if so do i recommend any specific book
i'm not sure why you would
read ibn cena or you know
abita as we often say
to understand aquinas i mean i think
avarose would be more important but
i'm not a i'm not a uh a specialist in
that sort of thing
i think actually just getting aquinas
down by himself
is probably enough of a task at the time
and i i wouldn't read selected writings
i would dive into the summa
summa teologia which is you know he says
created for beginners and it's organized
pretty systematically i mean there are a
lot of places where if you want to know
about this topic you have to jump into
something else instead of the question
on it
um i will say this and this is totally
unrelated to your
question except that it involves ibn
cena um
he he plays a role in
something that i'm myself interested in
which is tracing out the history
of the flavors or tastes in
philosophy medicine and the culinary
arts
a lot of people want to say oh there's
four tastes you know
sweet salty bitter and
sour and they're out they correspond to
stuff on our tongue that's all [ __ ]
we know that's that's that's actually
false and then you know sometimes
they'll say well you know there's umami
you know
or they'll say well in chinese you know
stuff or
indian stuff five tastes well no i mean
the ancient greeks
actually recognized eight or nine
different flavors
this is talked about in plato's timaeus
and then in aristotle's
um on the soul and on sensation and
apparently theophrastus talked about
although we don't have an awful lot
of his stuff and it was it was a very uh
common idea that carried through in the
middle ages and ibn cena
um he connected it these these flavor
profiles to
uh medical things and then that was
influential
not so much on people like thomas
aquinas but on
more naturally oriented
authors you know people who are
interested in like how do you tell if a
water is actually
safe or not in the middle ages they they
were consulting have been seen
on that uh dhruv there's a whole field
of deconstructivist critique and
architecture and several buildings have
been conceived in its response any
thoughts
since you teach dairydow you might be
able to weigh in nope i have no thoughts
on architecture at all i am not
i'm not anybody who has anything to
useful to say on that
um i do actually have a student
a former student uh from marist college
who is doing some really cool things
and we're connected on linkedin um i'm
trying to i'm blanking on his name
real nice guy and i can't say kid
anymore because he's probably
pushing pushing 30 at this time i think
about it
um and uh i know i i i don't i don't do
that that sort of thing
um i'm i'm much more you know about
texts and
uh about like ethics and stuff like that
so
not everybody has to do everything the
mere fact that i would i've
taught derrida or that i i've you know
written on him doesn't mean that i know
anything about architecture uh
skin in the academic game i've heard
there was a resurgence of interest of
hegel
in the 1970s what do you think with the
factors or the reason for this
is there another resurgence soon there's
a resurgence right now
um i i think that plenty of people are
interested in hegel the fact that you
know
um you know richard branham just came
out with a new book and we've got
uh two new translations of the
phenomenology of spirit i'm pointing up
there because that's that's where they
they live uh in addition to the good
miller translation
um i'd call that you know a lot of
interest in hegel
i don't know that there was a resurgence
of interest of hegel in the
the 70s um i mean there might have been
what we could call a
local resurgence of interest just like
when we talk about the
rediscovery of virtue ethics in the 20th
century wow that's all [ __ ] that's
that's there's a resurgence of virtue
ethics in anglo-american philosophy
but it never everywhere else people were
still interested in virtue ethics
you know so i i don't know that these
these
more local renaissances or
you know recoveries of interest
translated to much of anything
unless they produce a an interesting
literature
i mean when when did hegel quit being
popular in continental
thought um pretty much never right so
uh you know maybe in in
analytic philosophy i don't know um
but i don't remember there being like a
resurgence of interest in
hegel in analytic philosophy in the 70s
either
all right um william zen what are your
thoughts on william lane craig
i don't think about him at all because
um you know years ago when i
you know saw his stuff i thought well
this isn't
really worth engaging with um zoro malik
no one asked us to be or not to be what
is
so what is the concept of free will
those are totally unconnected ideas i
don't know
how they they're they're supposed to be
connected keith
says what is a good place to start with
phenomenology i know heidegger hysteria
et cetera can be quite dense or
difficult
is there a good beginner's text you can
recommend
um i mean i would what i do is i give
people kind of a smattering of texts and
i don't like throw them
directly into being in time you know or
withdrawals
ideas or anything like that you know
there's short texts that that you can
use um
like hustle has cartesian meditations
which is kind of
dry and can be tough but it's it's good
hustler also has a real nice
um article that he wrote for i think it
was encyclopedia britannica
phenomenology and he's describing what's
going on and so that that's where you
can get like well what husserlian
phenomenology
is about but hysterol is not the father
of phenomenology
by any means as a matter of fact there's
a whole bunch of people doing
phenomenology sometimes not calling it
but it's but
it's all you know the same sort of thing
mock shaler is
somebody you want to read and he's
pretty accessible
some of heidegger's essays if you have
some adequate guidance like i always
start students out with what is
metaphysics
um gabriel marcel is a phenomenologist
maurice blondell and henri bergson don't
call what they're doing phenomenology
blondel calls it the method of imminence
but you could read you know accion 1893
um berkson's essay on the immediate
givens of consciousness if that's not
phenomenology i don't know what is
uh you know so that that's that's
translated as time and free will but
the french title is that so there's all
sorts of ways to get into it
um and there were all these people who
were like influenced by it you know many
of them studied with his role
you know like start studied with him for
a little while ortega you gossip and so
you can look at what they have to say
um dietrich von hildenbrand is another
good person to take a look at
um he was a student of
mock shaler and he's got some good
discussions of it so i think there's a
lot of good places to to start
if you if your goal is to start at the
beginnings of the movement
that gets called phenomenology that's
useful
and you know speaking of mcintyre he's
got that biography
of edith stein another person you should
read too
um and there he's like tracing out you
know the whole
movement and when you when you get
mcintyre doing that you're getting a lot
of exposure to ideas so that could be
helpful
private name what is nietzsche's
epistemology he doesn't have an
epistemology
is he really a nihilist and relativist
does he really think there's no truth he
often seems to contradict himself
yeah it's not that simple um he's he's
not a
i mean he's not a neolis to begin with
right he tells you i am you know
nihilism is the problem so all you got
to do is read read around and that will
become quite clear um
he's trying to make you work he's trying
to make you
try to put together something of your
own um he's also criticizing a lot of
other people's
two easy ideas about uh things but
he doesn't have an epistemology as such
you'd have to reconstruct that right
and i don't know why why would he want
to do that rather than actually read the
nietzsche
and and see what he has to say made of
clay i'm wanting to know the difference
between the philosophy of history and
hegel's lectures on the
history of philosophy volume one um
i mean the that is the same thing right
volume one so uh
that's an easy one to solve do you think
any kind of social pack do you think any
contract theories are convincing i think
hobbes is interesting to study
but i believe you said he leaves much to
be desired what problems do you have
with his work well i mean
i don't buy into his his uh materialism
and mechanism to start with i mean
read the very beginning of leviathan and
see if you agree with how he
understands the human being um that's
kind of a
straightforward way to do it um are
there any social contract theories
that i find convincing it depends on
what you mean by convincing do i think
that there's any merit to them
some of them sure you know i often talk
about hobbes as
ha the person who outlines the worst
case scenarios that we don't want to
fall
into and he doesn't give us a solution
he more
sketches out a problem and then a
problematic response to that
solution but we should study him for
that that reason
um i've actually argued too that
in relation to mcintyre when mcintyre
talks about
you know nietzsche or aristotle i
actually say it should be hobbes
and nietzsche or aristotle um because i
think
the hobbesian problematic is so so
central
uh ruffy bumble says thank you for your
recent mcintyre video
in past amas you said mcintyre says
ethical problems
arise when someone in the past messed up
can you detail what this means in or
what works this is found i don't know
that i said that about mcintyre i've
i've said that i tell people in my
ethics classes that a good portion of
ethics is what we do
and how we figure things out after we've
screwed up um
but mac could mcintyre say something
like that sure
um i mean the process of
development for moral theories
and the traditions and institutions that
bear them
is a process of like getting some things
right and then
running into walls and saying okay what
do we do now or
those other people over there they seem
to have something that we're missing
that's just the way that mcintyre looks
at healthy
traditions what do you what what what
works would this be found in all of them
i mean that's kind of kind of core to
his his approach i would say
right all right um
what are my view this is from nam skye
what are my views on hannah rent how
applicable is it
in today's society i like hannah rent um
i i you know she calls herself a
political theorist and not a philosopher
i think she's a philosopher
and i enjoy reading her works i don't
always agree with her
you know like i think that she gets the
stoics wrong for example
in um what was the work
uh the act of life um
in any case uh i think she's wrong on
like epictetus on pro-erasis
but she always has interesting stuff to
say and she often
like gets us to the the important stuff
that we should be
considering um i think her origins of
totalitarianism is a great book
it's really a slog a lot of people
bought it after trump came to power
and then you know very promptly let it
be you know on their bookshelf or coffee
table rather than read it through
um but it's it's you know it's a good
work it makes contributions to
understanding
um fascism and nationalism
so what was the other question here how
applicable is it in today's society
depends on what the it is
i mean some of the things that she has
to say are very
time-bound and some of them are
you know broader broader scope and will
continue to go on for a while and i
think that her approach
in general can be said to be
um quite useful and and what i mean by
her approach
is you you look at the contemporary
situation and you need to have and this
is kind of like mcintyre right
you need to have engagement with other
points of view and this is part of what
politics is for her
right um there are certain limits to it
and you also need to use the stuff from
the past like say aristotle or
augustine is somebody she goes to
quite a bit as well without being like
slavishly
reproducers of that but using them to
problematize
stuff i find that very you know very
congenial because that's the kind of
stuff that i do myself but also very
attractive
in in a writer um
you know i would say that people like
there's a broader point like
mcintyre hana rant paul recur
you know maurice blondel in his own way
are doing this kind of
reconstructive work that
that remains very grounded very
competent
isn't it doesn't always have to be
completely correct but always has
something to offer us
you know um
yeah i guess that's enough about that
uh jackson says have i had any
experience reading or being given one of
those philosophy of x
x being star wars lord of the rings
seinfeld whatever i
you know i've read some of them i find
them to be a real mixed bag
some of them can be quite good some of
them are clearly written by people who
are more competent as fans
less competent as philosophers some of
them it's the reverse
um so i i can't say too much about that
except for this a little bit of like
academic gossip so marquette
had a center and i don't remember the
exact
name of it but but i i i eventually
connected with them
and i was talking with james south who's
now retired but was in charge of that
center and it was about like they did a
lot of stuff having to do with like
humanities and culture and he was
involved with a lot of those books and
so i asked him hey
is there any plan for like there to be a
venture brothers in philosophy because i
love the venture brothers and i'd write
about that you know
and he said you know what i proposed
that
and they shot it down they said no we're
not gonna do that and i was like
well why the hell would they do that
given all the crap that they've
published
why would they pass on the venture
brothers i don't know i i don't have any
clue
so you know maybe there's there's an
opening there for somebody to do some
writing on that
i was invited to to contribute to one of
the
uh game of thrones and philosophy things
i did a
a talk years and years back that was
very well received at a popular culture
conference about
uh moral theory and game and game of
thrones
uh song of ice and fire and
the the editors they wanted to have too
much editorial control
over what you would submit so i was like
i'm not you know
for something i'm contributing to you if
i write it it's going to be the way i
wrote it not
not what you choose to do with it so i
pulled out of the project even though it
was
being um staffed by somebody who was a
friend of mine
all right um
byron again i have a question that may
seem silly but it really bothers me if a
tree falls in a forest with no one to
hear it does it really
fall i've been flirting with idealism so
i'm not sure
i mean it depends on what kind of
idealism you have right if you've got
god in the picture
like barkley god hears the tree fall
if you have some other kind of idealism
i mean maybe hegel
spirit hears it fall or something like
that right hegel has a natural world
if you're if you're in any way a realist
about stuff obviously
it falls um if you're you know if you're
a pragmatist you could say well who
gives a [ __ ]
why are you worrying about this question
when you have other things you could be
concerned with
you know so it doesn't have to
necessarily bother you
jb hey nice to see you here says i never
heard stem lord before that is brilliant
well i can't take credit for it i've
seen it you know in a lot of
conversations people using that term but
it is it is a great
you know term because they it's the kind
of person who
you know another word for this is the
people who uh
were posting all those memes i [ __ ]
love science right
um and then they don't know anything
about science right or they know just a
little bit but they blow it up into this
wonderful thing or i like to call them
the
you know we have logic reason science
crowd
um it's kind of a you know an idolatrous
worship of
of these human activities as if they are
you know perfectly truth preserving and
and truth providing you know all right
uh
aaron what what i'm concerning is that
ai has such higher cognitive ability
than human beings in terms of
calculation precision
okay this is going back to that old
question accuracy and learning ability
i mean learning ability i would say no
because ai
machine learning is not actual learning
and you know we may find a new paradigm
remember too that that what we're
calling ai right now
is a paradigm of ai we had other
paradigms of ai
back in the day like you know expert
systems and
but we we found the limitations of those
and then we shifted to neural networks
and we're going to find the limitations
of those
neural networks by the way total you
know
total metaphor it's not it's not a
replication of
real neurons or anything like that um
we'll probably have other paradigms of
ai down the pike you know down the line
and they maybe have learning ability
um certainly calculation precision
accuracy
in very narrow areas so ais do
great in what they do great in and
they're crap for everything else
or they don't even they can't even like
register anything else
at this point you know it's really
interesting
everybody loves you know ibm's watson
um there's quite a few things where
once they started using watson as the
base like the you know the weather
channel uh things became less good
so we i think we probably have to look
at a lot of this on a case-by-case
basis and you know we do have to worry
too much about stupid human decisions
with respect to ai
like just we'll just leave it to the ai
to figure out right
and then we don't give it enough
parameters and
the ai will make stupid decisions as
well but i mean it's a real it's a real
issue it's a it's a it's a significant
thing
for us to to look at ion what are your
thoughts
on moxterner's oh just
here we go just lost it um union of
egoists um that's one of those things
where we had this expression
back in in the army and in uh
undergrad good work if you can get it
you know if you can actually make pull
it off
cool never seen anything remotely like
that happen in the past
but you know anything's possible right
all right um
muhammad reza do you think nature would
admire hitler or hate him he would have
found him pathetic
you know it was very clear you know in
in his
his works he thought that anti-semites
were
pretty pretty much stupid um made of
clay i don't know who said it but what
do you think about the saying that
morality came first from religion
and throughout the 20th and 21st century
morality came from the holocaust any
thoughts yeah i'd say that
the first part is half wrong and the
second part is entirely wrong
um those are my thoughts on that
august says i've been on a spinoza kick
recently do you have any tips or
warnings for reading spinoza and
learning about spinoza
yeah i mean if you're going to read um
like the teological political treaties
read hobbs first because
spinoza lifted a lot of that stuff
straight out of hobbs
and so you can you know see the
connections there the ethics you've got
to wrap your head around that kind of
crazy moral geometrical that he's into
the most important thing i'll say and
this goes for
spinoza this goes for hegel
and this also goes for
this book and this guy nick land
is don't get sucked into a mystique you
know there's there's these figures
in philosophy that people talk about
and they oh the great genius oh my god
there's
the mind of god there or something
something crazy like that
and when you go to it and you don't
you don't have that mystique you're like
this is interesting stuff but
it's not so mind-blowing as these people
are making it out to be so what the
hell's going on there it's sort of like
people who drop
acid and go to the grateful dead and
they're like oh man
i had this revelation hegel's great
you know spinoza's good nick land okay
um none of them are like super super
geniuses that you know you have to like
have this really difficult revelation to
understand or anything like that
um as a matter of fact i'll i'm sure
somebody's gonna ask me about nick land
later on so i'll just say
i've been you know reading fang numina
very underwhelmed
it's the sort of stuff that you know
basically you'd go to a
continental philosophy conference and
you'd hear papers like this all the time
back in the 90s
you know it's not bad but it's not it's
not mind-blowing or anything
and so approach spinoza in the same way
don't don't like
automatically assume that oh this must
be really super
important or anything like that spinoza
is no smarter than descartes
or live nits for that matter
he's an interesting guy he's got
interesting things to say he's got a
cool system that he puts together which
is pretty implausible but
is it cool to check out just like hume
is cool to check out too but
um you don't want to like get sucked
into this this
uh mystique trap uh brandon i'm curious
you if you know h.g wells outline of
history and his advocacy
advocacy for a global government founded
on a proto-wikipedia
world brain organization he thought of
himself as a conscience
um i guess he would be conscient in the
respect of having read you know
perpetual peace but he's not a conscient
in any other important way i guess
um yeah i mean wells plagiarized that
outline of history uh we know that for
for sure and it's not very good
when he plagiarized so um
it's one of those things that you know
you read once and you're like
okay typical kind of stuff of its time
and then you move on
all right rajat how does an individual
who did their bachelor's in something
totally unrelated get into philosophy
and academia in general
how can they know what they should even
pursue
same way as anybody else who doesn't
have a bachelor's i guess
you know there's obviously some
philosophers
who have stood the test of time and
you're going to want to read like plato
and aristotle and the stoics and
augustine you know and then
you kind of you know as you're doing
that you're going to get some
some more information and some ideas and
hopefully
you're engaging other people and not
just you know like retiring to your
corner to read all by yourself
and you'll find like new tracks to go
down
you don't have to have it all figured
out all at once by the way i'm going to
pause here and tell everybody about
something that i've got
coming down the pike so some of you may
know that i have been
doing writing on medium and that i
created
a medium publication called practical
rationality which right now is just my
own essays
but eventually might include some essays
by you know some people who
i'm friends or colleagues with like you
know my wife andy shaka who's very
brilliant or
you've seen mark smith here another
another brilliant younger
scholar down in south africa and other
people as well
and one of the one of the things i want
to write about
is a whole set of um short essays
and i don't know exactly what i'm going
to call them i thought about the word
letters to a young philosopher you know
sort of like how rilka has
letters to a young poet and daniel
bellude has letters to a young chef
but maybe that's a little bit too tired
of a of a trope
you know but they're going to be advice
so they're going to be advice about
these sorts of questions
and questions that people have been
asking me in other places or they email
me or they ask his youtube comments or
you know their amas which are good
questions like okay where do i start
and how do i know that i'm reading the
right stuff you know or
um you know my professor like i saw
somebody
post a youtube comment today where like
my professor doesn't want me reading x
and my immediate response was well [ __ ]
your professor you know
i mean you it's a free country you can
read whatever the hell you want you know
read what the professor wants you to
read but then read the other stuff too
right how are they going to stop you
right we're not living in a
a totalitarian state where they
they'll they'll throw you in jail for
having the wrong book or something
um and so i'm going to write some essays
about that that kind of stuff and so
this question
is is a good question how do i get
started you know um
and i always say start with plato uh you
might find useful to go to my
self-directed study videos i haven't
done as many of them as i would like to
um but i've got them there for you know
a good bit of ancient philosophy which
will keep you busy for a while plato
aristotle the epicureans the stoics
cicero
i've got one on early christian thought
got one on anselm
i think that's all i've got right now um
but you know
those those sort of things could be
could be quite helpful for you so
all right um
chad says the light is on your hair
making you look like a superior
intellectual entity
spitting straight facts yeah so it's
because we got this uh
there we go we got this skylight right
and where i'm sitting
i was trying to avoid this but and they
see me moving around too but um
you know the sun just it keeps beaming
in so
not much i can do about that uh audrey
or andre rather uh what do i think about
saint bernard clairvoya as a philosopher
um as a philosopher not much as a
theologian
pretty interesting um he has a lot to
say about affectivity
it's not somebody i really read a lot
and and can talk
very well about um somebody who actually
has a good book on him is uh
joe song at yourself so i would i would
check him out
um christopher would i consider
something that's made up of stats and an
inductive argument
i i would say it's the pretense to an
inductive argument
i mean we probably have to look at case
by case
wouldn't we um
drew says stuck after learning some
basic german any suggestions how to move
forward if i want to read philosophy
um yeah i do have a couple suggestions
and this would go for other languages as
well
so get yourself
instead of having instead of relying on
a german to english
you know dictionary get yourself a
a a dictionary in german for german
people
look up words in that because i i mean i
i didn't do that with german so much but
my german has never been all that great
but i did that with french with the big
robot dictionary
that my mom got for me um when she was
in paris
and man did that help you know to boost
your vocabulary
um reading uh in german is very
important you know somebody who's pretty
easy to read and as fun
is uh kafka and get his works and um
use them you know and look at that like
crazy light
um
so i think those would be helpful um
if your goal is to do to be able to
speak it well
um watch german tv shows
and try to find places
where you can talk with native german
speakers that's that's helpful too
so all right peter i'm new and going
through your medium top 10
best philosophy books for beginners
which is why i chose aquinas selected
writings oh okay yeah that's a good
place to start but
don't stick with that go i mean you can
find the summa online
so jump into the summer august as a
period of philosophy scholasticism seems
pretty vague to me
as and people talk about it but the
details seem fuzzy
you have a suggestion where to start
with scholasticism
uh peter abelard um he would be one of
the early scholastic writers
um he you can find his stuff i mean some
people consider ant's almost scholastic
but he's really
he's really not a scholastic he's really
still a monastic writer and he's kind of
suey generous you know his own his own
thing
just like you know david pumpkins right
um
who else um i mean there's a whole
bunch of scholastic writers
you know a lot of them are coming out of
these cathedral schools
some of them are coming out of
monasteries
and then you get the the boom in um
you know the universities that you give
us people like bonaventure and
thomas aquinas um but yeah people are
pretty vague you're right
people are pretty vague about what
scholasticism is
i don't think it names just one thing i
think it names a whole bunch of
different approaches
the way that franciscans and dominicans
approach things were kind of different
so it's it's a it's a good term not to
abuse
you could say um
jacob says if i'm going to a continental
school for undergraduate is a hard is it
a hard transition to get into analytic
for a graduate school why not read the
analytics stuff on your side
you know it's not like you're the only
stuff you can study is what you read in
class
is it um again it's a free country if
you want to
learn the the history of analytic
philosophy you can
probably go to the library and get
russell's
logical atomism and some of his other
essays and read some wittgenstein and
read some
you know air and
those people and then move into rile and
austin and you know it's
you could do that or you could read some
contemporary stuff you probably want to
get down
the stuff with uh lewis and possible
world semantics because that's kind of
uh trendy still at this point in time
but
it's not it's not you know difficult to
do
um zeitgeist do i have any special
advice for handling addiction
uh i don't have any special advice
um i would say you know you focus on the
things that
you can actually have some control over
and you definitely make use of the
support networks
that you can find and you know
um addiction is is very is very tough
and i you know we have quite a few
problems with that
in my family uh over the years
um so you know i'm pretty sympathetic to
it
you know the other thing too is it's
easy to get into this
shame cycle of you know you set your
goal too high for yourself like
oh man i'm going to totally kick x y z
and then you fail and then you feel like
[ __ ] so you return to
x y z whatever it happens to be i mean
it could just be like um
watching television shows hour after
hour right
it could be drugs could be could be uh
sex it could be
alcohol it could be anything you like
right
um and you know you will get into that
that that shame cycle from time to time
well what do you do when that happens
that's when you reach out to your
support networks and that's when you
learn to be
forgiving towards yourself without being
without taking it too easy on yourself
and you know you um you pick yourself up
and you say okay back to day one
and now we're gonna keep grinding away
at it you know
i will say this too one of the most
liberating
things that i for for
my clients who i do philosophical
counseling with
um to hear is and also my students
because i i often have um i try to
maintain some boundaries i like to push
them
you know into getting some actual
therapeutic counseling
because i i don't want to be both a
professor and do that with them
but hearing that you're not the only one
struggling with a particular
thing is very liberating because
often it feels like you are the only
person
who's dealing with this or dealing with
it in this way
and you can feel lonely and isolated and
and that
often stands in the way of reaching out
for help
so i think those are i mean those are
probably the only things i can
i can tell you um
doug another interesting question what
are some good philosophers of love
uh you know i mean read aristotle's nick
mccain ethics not at books
eight and nine and not just for the
three kinds of friendship but all the
other stuff in there
um augustine you know another important
person i would say
um you know mary wollstonecraft is
is an interest she has a lot of
interesting things to say
not just in her vindication of the
rights of women but in other places as
well
somebody who learned the hard way about
about love
i mean there's all sorts of people out
there
i would you know i will say this
c.s lewis's the four loves is good
but don't buy into the four loves
[ __ ] you know this this like
well there's philia and
uh you know agape and these are totally
different from each other and the greeks
all called it this way that's all
[ __ ]
um it's it's a nice shorthand for
different kinds of
talking about about things but it i mean
if you read plato's dialogues like you
read the symposium
agape arrows they're both thrown in
there same with philia same with storge
all of those are just being kind of used
indiscriminately
um there's no there's no rigid
distinction like like a lot of
people like to make all right um
brayden have i read non-contractual
society by virginia held i have not
although i probably should because i
like virginia held
um brandon husserl and heidegger
co-wrote the
encyclopedia article i think i don't
know i all i know is it says historical
on it
uh zeno of valea what do you think of
eternal recurrence
i i think it's kind of a dead dead point
i i don't pay attention to
that stuff i'm not really interested in
it anti-gay would you ever include cat's
cradle in your sci-fi speculative
fiction series
so the question you always have to ask
when when you're proposing somebody to
go into the sci-fi
speculative fiction series and sci-fi by
the way is a version of speculative
fiction
is is there a coherent
narrative world spanning more than one
book
cat's cradle is a book
i like to do things where there's like a
series and there's a coherent narrative
world to explore
so like for example are they up here uh
next thing that we're going into after
we finish up with um
our scott backers prince of nothing
trilogy
the third book in that is uh philip jose
farmer's world of tears right
and so there's a coherent six volume uh
narrative world being developed there is
cat's cradle
involving something like that if not
maybe it's not a good fit
you know um
doug ernst becker kind of sucked the
soul out of me are you a fan
uh no i haven't read becker for for a
long time
um zeno have you read the birth and
death of meaning if so what do you think
of it
haven't read it so um
shrey have you ever looked into judah
krishnamurti's work
no i have not jack what are your
thoughts on henri bergstone
i'm a big fan of bergson i like him
quite a bit um
i actually have a bunch of uh berg's own
volumes in french that i picked up
at a used bookstore in st louis
one of the places that i used to go to
when i was in
southern illinois university carbondale
we drive over to st louis and if you
don't know st
louis is a it's not a university town as
such but there are a lot
of universities and colleges in st louis
and this guy was tapped into the
university community
so when a professor would die he would
go
and buy up their books and i wonder if
where they are they're on my shelf
somewhere but
not easily reachable um so i've got like
you know five of of bergstone's works
in french because that the guy who used
to teach him i guess maybe at slu or
something
died and i i acquired them so i i like
him
all right um
oh we're now we're going to get into
some metal questions
great shirt by the way what is your
favorite sabbath album for me
it's sabotage so
i am probably going to
take some some sabbath fans off it's not
an aussie album although i do like the
the aussie albums even never say die
isn't bad
um but i would say
my favorite sabbath album
is probably the mob rules followed by
born again mob rules is with dio right
born again
a lot of people panned i love um
that's with ian gillen and then you know
i also like the eternal idol um i think
that's glenn hughes on that one is the
singer
right so but i you know i love
sabbath's uh sabbath's um
body of work you know uh there's a lot
of stuff from the aussie years that i do
like
so all right um
michael anderson are you interested in
any michel foucault
works like uh like these
[Laughter]
i mean i have a whole shelf of foucault
works um
as a matter of fact i put out you know a
whole sequence of core concept videos on
his technologies itself
not too long ago and just this week i've
been releasing podcast episodes on
technologies of the self so
yeah you could say i do like foucault i
mean i don't agree with him a lot of the
time he's sort of like hume right
he's cool to read very interesting and
useful in certain ways but
sometimes full of [ __ ] and you know um
you gotta you know be
be fairly uh you
you don't want to be like a believer
right um
but yeah i i i've been reading for co
was the first i mean i first encountered
foucault back in undergraduate so
yeah um
let's see what else i can take here
i'm going to try to not take people
who've already asked a lot of questions
um oh here's an interesting personal
question if it's not too personal
how did you get through losing the
ability to run after messing your knee
up did it change the way you exercise
now trying to gather ideas about coping
with disability
i wasn't doing a hell of a lot of
running uh as like exercise
before i messed up my my knee
uh and for those who don't know i did a
video on this a while back
it was when like 2012
2013 i um
we were out on the beach at montauk
which is at the very end of
long island in new york and it was
me my wife and and my kids and it was
like towards the end of our
our stay we go we would go before the
the season started because otherwise
it's too expensive and there's too many
people and you know we'd like swim and
have good seafood
and just relax for for like uh you know
an extended period it was a lot of fun
to do and the waves were kind of high
that day
and it was towards the end of the the
day we were actually going to be
getting ready to go in and i went into
the water to like
wash sand off of myself and the waves
again were pretty high they were coming
in pretty hard
and i remember my daughter was like
shouting to me
she was further up the beach and i
turned and suddenly like a big wave
hit me and i went under and i i heard
like
a pop like i could hear it in my
in my body and um
i knew i had to get out of the surf so i
like
you know pulled myself up onto the shore
and then i tried to get up and my leg
just like flopped out from under me and
i was like oh this is this is bad and
then the pain hit
right and it turns out i tore
two of the ligaments in that left knee
at that point in time the acl and the
mcl
so it's pretty wiggly and i had to do a
lot of
rehab i never did get like the you know
new tendons
or ligaments put in there was a
misunderstanding with my doctor
i probably should have done that but
didn't do it
and the um you know what i've done is
just strengthened the muscles as best if
i
as i could around it i mean i was on a
crutch for a long time i had to wear a
brace for a while
i still do use like when i go to work
out i put knee braces on
because the other knee is not in great
shape either it's had to compensate for
the screwed up knee
um but you know i can i can do other
exercises i don't have to run
i can take long walks i can go on the
treadmill or
the uh i like the elliptical
you know i do a lot of rowing too if i'm
doing cardio
and um
what else i mean i gotta be a little
careful with it i can't do
some of the things i used to like to do
like racquetball
um my wife actually proposed to me that
you know maybe we'll do this
zumba thing and i'm you know if i do
that i got to be really careful
not to screw it up um wearing a brace
might be sufficient for that
so there's all you know you have kind of
restrictions um sometimes it gives me
some pain
but it actually it's not too bad for me
um
so it could be much worse there and
there are many people who have much
worse
disabilities to deal with i don't even
really think of it as a disability
quite frankly in part because it's it's
kind of
on the trivial end you know but i
suppose it actually is a disability
now now that i think about it um and it
was it was kind of a bummer
um it was also sort of a wake up moment
you know
you're in your 40s you can't do the same
stuff that you'd like to do
um i mean it doesn't stop me from doing
weights
it doesn't stop me from doing other
things i'd like to do so
i think that's probably one of the big
key things does your disability keep you
from being able to
enjoy the activities you'd like to
engage in
all right um
mihai is is it just me or is kant
repeating himself a lot really a lot
it's you i wouldn't say he's
repeating himself a lot uh coffee smug
does stoic sage always experience good
feelings like joy or is there no
necessary connection between good
feelings and being a sage
i'd say that's a problem for the sage to
worry about i mean
um who knows
ask ask one if you can find them right
dylan do you think nihilism is
inexorable if god doesn't exist no
why would it be uh leo how would you
explain the role of prudence in the
attainment of happiness in thomas
aquinas's ethics
well um prudence it helps you
to you know like with aristotle which
thomas is taking this from
to figure out how to adapt you know
means to ends and
it helps you you know develop the
virtues and all that sort of stuff and
those play a role in whether you are
going to be happy or not i mean
happiness for thomas is not having the
virtues but
you know rectitude of will does help to
get you there right so
um just skipped a little bit
let's see if i can find where we were
um
well here's an interesting question um
how do you how do did you know what you
like how can one know what they really
like in life
one can't know how how and can they even
pursue something i mean
it's not like you start out as a total
blank right you know you like some
things
and you find out what you like by trying
things out and very often
you you know hear from somebody else
hey you should if you like this you
should try this out so you know great
example if you like black sabbath
um you probably would enjoy the band
orchid you know
you can look them up and then find their
stuff and listen to them and see whether
you like it or not i mean that's
that's that's generally how you do it um
all right uh i'm gonna skip down a
little bit
landon the kojito is it an argument
kentaka argues it is best understood as
a performative thought act just
demonstrating the existential
self-verifiability of certain utterances
thoughts depends on what you mean by the
kojito if you mean the formula
kojito ergosome or kojito ergo
you know what is it existo um
is it an argument no it's not an
argument um it's just
an assertion of something but it
also depends on what you consider to be
an argument there's no like single one
agreed upon thing for that we also talk
about the kojito
as especially in french philosophy as
the space that descartes opened
up by considering oneself to be
a thinking thing immediately after
you know saying that a thinking
substance in meditation two he goes on
to
outline what are the different modes of
thought so i am a thing that
asserts denies a thing that wills wills
against
feels you know goes on and all that that
some people consider that the code you
tell
right so it really depends on what you
mean by it
um
a b do you know anyone other than eugene
thacker who works on philosophy of
horror
um
no i don't know it's a good question i
mean
um the guy who was associated with
speculative realism graham harmon has a
whole book on lovecraft so i guess
that's probably horror right i imagine
if you dig around you'll probably find a
whole bunch of people
um
let's see alexander do you think
philosophy is getting obsolete
no i'd say it's the opposite um
i mean obsolete is a relative
term obsolete in relation to what or
obsolete for what you know
like model t ford car is obsolete
uh stoicism isn't obsolete you know
even though it's way older but used for
different purposes right
um all right let's scroll down a little
bit
uh kashif what book would you reckon for
an introduction to western philosophy
i would read uh cobblestone you know i
i have never found a history of
philosophy that has
turned out to be better than frederick
cobblestone's history of philosophy i've
seen
you know like grayling has a recent
history of philosophy out there but
it's not you know it's not great it's
not bad
but it has some big gaps in it um
cobblestone isn't perfect but that's
what we used for grad school
and um he's probably not going to steer
you wrong
so yeah um
joshua says uh how do you think
nietzsche
will be viewed in a hundred years that's
a good question
i mean i i don't know how you could
predict what
somebody's gonna be thought of like in a
hundred years
i will say this if the human race is
still around right if the planet hasn't
been destroyed
um people will still be reading
nietzsche a hundred years from now
and thinking about nietzsche so that's
that's probably as far as
we can go um
maybe there'll be a you know group of
people that call themselves nietzscheans
like in the andromeda show
right something like that
all right uh any how to reconcile the
idea of hard determinism and moral
responsibility
you don't if you're a hard determinist
moral responsibility
it's kind it becomes kind of trivial or
meaningless
i will tell you this really funny uh
story that i've told before
so when i would teach internal
philosophy classes at indiana state
prison
i would always you know we'd always have
a textbook and there'd be a thing on
determinism and there'd be some guy
who'd
like a light bulb would go on in his
head and he'd say wait a second
so if determinism is true then
i didn't have a choice about committing
my crime and therefore
the judge should have found me or that
you know the jury or whatever
[ __ ] or the prosecutor because a lot of
these guys actually played you know they
did plea bargains
should have found me innocent and the
ceo should let me out of the prison
right now
and then within a minute there'd be some
guy next to him would say
you dummy don't you realize that if hard
determinism holds for you
it holds for everybody else so that co
out in the hallway he is just as
determined to do what he does
as you are and the judge who found you
you know guilty
he was just as determined as as you were
to commit the crime
and so you know in this respect
everything just becomes you know
it doesn't make any change in things
right um
kind of an interesting idea all right
invo
info voy are you interested in
contemporary philosophy of mind if not
particularly is that because it's not
great because it's picking through ideas
that have been expressed before
other reasons i'm not interested in it
in part because i'm interested in other
things and there's only 24 hours in a
day and
most of the stuff that i see coming out
of philosophy of mind like when i go to
conferences
just is not that interesting a lot of it
is kind of rehashing
old stuff because people don't read
enough of the old stuff to realize
they're reinventing wheels
or it's you know really naive you know
making these sweeping assumptions about
like the brain is just like a computer
stuff like that um but a lot of it is i
just don't have the time i mean if i'm
gonna spend the time
reading this other stuff that's time
taken away from
from those things i'll also say too
people are always asking me what's the
best
secondary work on this i wouldn't know i
mean i
this is what occupies me i don't have
the time to read all sorts of
secondary literature anymore unless it's
on something that i'm
i'm reading you know um
the undertaker where do you stand on
gender philosophy in any book on it you
want to recommend i don't know what
gender philosophy means maybe philosophy
of gender
is what you're saying or philosophy that
has something to say about gender and
sexuality
uh i mean starting point is mary
wollstone crafts
vindication of the rights of women right
she certainly talks about gender quite a
bit there
virginia hell do people brought up
earlier is somebody
uh interesting in terms of ethics of
care um
i mean you probably want to read judith
butler's gender trouble um
you can disagree with it but at least
it's kind of setting the
the tone right all right um
[Music]
kevin says i just cleared my philosophy
semester one by listening to your
lectures thank you so much
hope you also read the books because the
lectures are always
based on the readings the lectures are
just supposed to be
a means to an end of understanding
things better
but i'm glad that they were helpful for
you uh multiply finished my ma in
religion and i'm trying to apply to phds
currently
i'm interested in duluth and dairydon
religious pluralism any advice
um good luck i mean i don't know that
there are that many
religion programs that are really into
dairydodd to lose
i i would probably pick up some other
stuff to
um interest them and focus on uh
because dairy down to lose are very
interesting
but you know they're they're certainly
not
like the go-to i would say for thinking
about religion
um all right uh michael was schopenhauer
severely depressed and just negative
about life
no uh phosphor and
arrived at his pessimistic conclusions
through
you know a lot of thinking things
through um
it's always it's always a mistake to try
to do that kind of
biography oh they were just this and
that's why it turned out that way
um that's a good way to not understand
the
philosophers you're looking at i mean
you may as well say about him
that the reason he uh uh you know
thought about things the way he did is
because he's a big fat guy you know
or something like that right um
wavy aside from his dialogues having
been written similar to plays in their
format
do we see any other examples of plato's
former life as a playwright
influencing his philosophical work so we
don't know that plato was a playwright
we know that he was a poet
and tragedy and comedy were
part of poetry but there were other
kinds of poetry as well and we don't
know what plato actually
wrote um before he he left poetry behind
we don't know that he wrote stuff like
euripides or
or eshless or aristophanes we know he
can he can
imitate them as he does like in the
symposium for example
um but no yeah i don't think we know
enough about that that's a good question
um
ahmed what's my opinion on the no fap
movement do i believe that stoics
practice nofap themselves
um i think it's irrelevant and it's a
thing where
boys who aren't real men you know try to
have one more thing they can control
over sort of like
you know with eating disorders right and
which is not
totally a a uh gendered thing but often
does fall much more on
on women than and girls than on boys and
men
um i think that there's a lot of things
that guys get drawn into as well and
it's just kind of silly
um it's not it's not you know i mean if
you want to like control your sexuality
that way i guess you could do that but
you know
it's a weird thing to like get obsessive
about
um what the stoics would suggest is
you know a rational use of your sexual
faculties
you know is it a rational use i i don't
know
i think in a lot of cases of people it's
not a
110th street production about to be a
phd philosophy student at depaul in the
fall any advice on things to do before
entering the program or what to expect
say hi to kevin thompson if he's still
there he was a guy who was down at
southern illinois university and then
moved up to depaul i don't know if he's
still there now
but he and i had some good conversations
and i've actually got a few books on my
shelf that came from
from him
yeah i mean
if i was going to like think about
advice i would give to a young
philosophy grad student um
part of it would be don't let yourself
get too
drawn into again like mystiques or
prestiges about
oh this is we gotta read this person
they're so important you know
so brilliant because 10 years from now
that person guaranteed
um most people are not going to be
focusing on anymore the you know
the philosopher de jour who everybody
has to know
and you know be willing to like move
around
uh you know you you may come in and
identify yourself as a as a delusion and
everyone will be looking at you as the
deluse person
but you might read aristotle and be like
ah i guess uh
these you know contemporary continental
people were wrong about
aristotle and there's something really
cool there and i'm gonna study aristotle
now
that's okay to do you know you're not
letting anybody down
as a graduate student by not like
spending all your time reading
obsessively this
person or that person you know so
all right uh rolled on are you familiar
with the trick von hildenbrand's work
the nature of love
got it on my shelf so yeah um
raving says have you ever discussed
walker percy's novel the thanatos
syndrome
i have not um leon you
mentioned augustine in reference to love
what would you recommend to read well i
mean the confessions right off the bat
right
he talks about about his own loves in
the confessions
um his uh um
his uh on christian doctrine
um probably on on free choice of the
will
would be good to read um city of god
will have some useful stuff in there
uh in different places so those will
keep you busy city of god is a big
thick book here here it is right here
you're gonna read your way through a lot
of stuff if you if you read that one
so um
all right uh
oh this is nice rainy mcgee your class
at marist was outstanding thank you so
much oh it's a former student here
it's always nice to hear back from them
um
and to uh see that they you know i
what i really love to hear from students
so rainy you might
you might email me or message me like in
linkedin
i always love to hear what from
our classes turned out to be
useful for you at some point in your
life
that's that's something that i i really
enjoy oh we have a little
visitor here little miss sassy pants
come here we'll see if she wants to to
join us for
for a minute um thanks michael that's
that's very
nice of you oh she almost took it she
almost
biffed it there we go there's my big
girl
many of you are familiar with sassy our
18 and a half year old cat
the only survivor of our four-legged
family
she's been sleeping up here the entire
time and you know
woke up and now she's going to get down
probably get something to eat i imagine
um get something to drink so i'll let
her
let her alone it's going to be rough
when she goes you know
the dog's going and her sister teensy
going
i really miss them but um i am her
person
so all right uh
let's see oh it just skipped a bit but
that's good because
we're got about 10 minutes left uh
before i have to get on to working on
on some other stuff and another event um
let me grab
some people who haven't had a chance to
say something
um
louis says what are your tips to a
wannabe future philosophy
college professors and my master's
degree and still have some problem
understanding
how many hours i should study it's going
to be a rough
time i mean the job market you don't
want to deceive yourself about it
it was crap when i first came out of
grad school
it is terrible now i mean marquette
university
just fired uh a whole bunch of people
and got rid of their um visiting
assistant professors who by the way they
were paying like pittance wages to
they're paying like
you know 40 grand a year which means you
know this doesn't go very far here in
milwaukee
um carthage college actually fired 15
tenured professors over the summer so
it's a rough time
if you can get it that's that's
fortunate
most of the jobs are being taken up by
people
who have degrees and pedigrees from
upper tier universities so you want to
go to
the highest tier university you can go
to
not because it's rational not because
that's fair or anything that's just the
way the game is
is played right now um so that you know
it kind of sucks
it can make you a little pessimistic i
would say it's important to um
it's important to learn how to
um develop support systems
and you know it's going to be
psychologically tough to
try to get into um full-time jobs
here's a good question from sean was
teaching an indiana state prison more
rewarding than a professor at higher
education
when i was teaching at indiana state
prison i was a professor in higher
education i was an
assistant professor at ball state
university on a
renewable contract so i couldn't get
tenure or promotion
i mean my boss actually said you know
that i would have by the time i left i
would have been a
tenured associate professor because i
had published so much and done
done a lot of stuff um it was rewarding
yeah it was it but
you know i've also enjoyed the places
that i've taught um
and each place has had
a different kind of uh set of challenges
and
opportunities so um
the thing that i really liked about
indiana state prison and teaching
with with those guys was um
i mean i could relate to them because
you know
um there were a lot of
ways in which they they weren't that
different than than the rest of us
uh and i i've struggled with the kind of
anger problems that could easily
get you into prison
but i also got to teach like a vast
variety of classes
and i got to teach some of the same
students over and over again so i got to
see them
progress and develop and
you know to be part of their their
education
so that was that was quite rewarding for
me
uh let's see here
vinnie says what i think what do i think
of private liberal arts schools
like amherst versus large research
schools like ucla for undergrad
philosophy majors
will there be a big difference in the
quality of education i don't know either
of them
you know like i've never been to either
of them and i don't know anyone who
works at them so i don't know
um i can tell you this that
different students thrive in different
environments so it's good to figure out
where you fit in
some people really do want to have a
small liberal arts school some other
people want to have a big state school
some people want to try to get into
harvard or yale or you know
university of chicago people like me
could get a good
education anywhere because i'm pretty
self-motivated and i
hit the library and you know uh
often didn't take no for an answer when
people closed doors
it all kind of depends on what what
you're like and
you can go to a top-tier school and the
professors could be crap or
you know just not treat you very well or
they're captivated by this sort of thing
and it's not
it's not what you want to study
i will say this schools are kind of like
a black box
unless you know somebody on the inside
you can never
really be sure if a program is actually
any good
you could go to a place with a big name
professor
and they could be having a bad year
because they're going through a divorce
or
you know death in the family and they're
just not available for you
or they um they turn out to be pricks
you know and and don't want to have
anything to do with you or they're
sexual harassers like john searle
right um or thomas poga um
so it it you know the best thing to do
is the places that you want to go try to
find out as much from the
inside as you can and there's like
forums
that you can go to these days you know
um gavin has a good question here does
it bother you when people call nietzsche
nihilist when a major driving force of
his work is to find meaning and
nothingness
through the manifestation of the self
does it bother me
not really um except in the sense that
like people
saying things that they like heard
somewhere and should know better about
because it's easily you can easily find
the information
i guess it does bother me but it doesn't
bother me like oh
i'm mad or anything like that i'm just
like come on
you know um and yeah nietzsche
his his project is to try to figure out
how do we create
new values given that the old values are
falling apart you know so
all right oh this is nice so a little
follow-up about depaul
uh professor thompson is still here and
is the graduate director yeah so
given my my regards i think he'll be
very surprised
that i i uh because i wasn't you know i
was kind of a smart ass
and not really going anywhere
at the time that he knew me actually
i'll tell you a really great story
about thompson that was a very important
moment for me
so we were walking along
on campus and i was like super into
derrida at the time
and i said something about
derrida says this and i it was something
that was like my own interpretation
and i don't even remember what it was
and then he said where does darydes say
that
and i was like well in this work here
he says this and then he's like yeah but
that's not what you said
so where does dario say the thing that
you said
and i was like puzzling about it and i
was and i got a little bit pissed off
too and i was like
there's i i can't be wrong about this
and
then i finally said i guess he doesn't
say that and then he said
exactly now now you're actually on the
road to figuring out what the hell darey
die actually does say about this sort of
thing
which might not be you know as sexy as
you like
or as interesting as you like but at
least is grounded in the texts
so that was a great thing to say right
it was a great teaching moment
um all right so i'm not going to get to
everybody's uh
questions because we're going to be
wrapping up here pretty soon so let me
see what i can
go out on um
oh here's a good one from colomous why
do you think that a lot of people who
would normally agree with increasing the
minimum wage in the case of their own
job
will disagree with it in general and
bring up small businesses
uh because they're full of [ __ ] you know
because they haven't researched things
adequately there's
plenty of you know stuff out there that
show that raising the minimum wage
doesn't like make prices go through the
roof you know
and if if your small business can't
operate without
um with without screwing people over on
their wages your small business
according to you know capitalism as a
general idea doesn't deserve to continue
on right if you can't
if you can't get people to work for you
at a decent
age then there's something wrong with
your business model
and you know people buy into all sorts
of silly ideology
especially here in america about you
know what the you know
what the minimum wage ought to be and
they just don't take the time to
inform themselves and they essentially
are
just like feedback loops for you know
ideology about that it's too bad because
you know the human brain can be do a lot
better
but what are you gonna do you know you
just
tell them you know direct them towards
the stuff that shows that the minimum
wage
raising it is not going to kill the
economy or anything like that right
um let's see what else we can
go out on um
uh let me scroll down and see if we got
anything
oh spencer here's a good there's a good
one um
how do you think albert camus
perspective on life
changes in the plague versus the myth of
sisyphus so the question to ask there
is not the plague versus the versus
mythicism
it would be the other pieces that would
go along with it like letters to a
german friend
uh or the rebel or you know the other
things from that time along with the
plague um
you know camus in the uh
um the rebel says listen back when i
wrote
the myth of sisyphus i said the
philosophical question in the face of
the absurd is suicide
now it's murder you know and so i think
there's a transformation that takes
place
you'll also notice him in letters to a
german friend talking about
decency and justice you might say well
how can an absurdist talk about that
well kamu's an absurdist who does talk
about that
because those are those are still
options those are still available
for us um
there was another question um
yeah here we go this is a good one to go
out on um
from deepon gupta
and it's about other youtube philosophy
teachers so i don't watch a lot of other
people's videos
obviously because i don't have a lot of
time for that um
and and i you know i i'm not looking for
other people to
to teach me usually um so i'm not a good
commenter on that i will say this i have
a friend and colleague
whose name is davood gosli
i'm actually going to type it here in
the
uh the uh little chat
thing and he and i have been talking
for quite a while he lives over in
he teaches in macau and lives in hong
kong
at this point in time he got married but
hopefully he's coming back to
to this this continent before too long
he's got a great youtube channel and
very thoughtful um he's a guy who
he studies philosophy his degree is
actually in psychology
experimental psychology but he is very
thoughtful
i i really when i watch his videos i get
a lot out of the works
um so if if i was going to suggest you
watch somebody
it would be him let me also show you a
little
something before we go there's sassy
finding the sunlight
she sees she sees you on the camera she
doesn't like being on camera
so all right i'm gonna say have a good
day
at this point and um didn't get to
everybody's
questions but um i never do
but thanks for all your questions
comments
and we'll do another one of these next
month i've also got the you know
political
theory and practice discussion coming up
and some other online things as well
i think you can always check the reason
i owe calendar
go to my facebook page those are the
good places to find all that stuff
so all right i hope all of you have a
great uh rest of the day
whatever it happens to be i know some of
you this is deep in the evening hours
for you and maybe some of you this is
early in the morning here we're
approaching 1
1 35 in
in the afternoon so i'll see all of you
next time